meagan Markel who we have learned isn't
in a rush to get her body back after
baby Megan hasn't been hitting the gym
she hasn't been in any hurry to get back
into shape no hard training no weights
she's enjoying this time she's being
gentle to herself after Megan's first
public appearance since giving birth
some were throwing shade at the
Duchess's post partum looks even saying
she looked matronly and tired shame on
those trolls who have criticized her
appearance she is a new mother Megan's
been up in the night she's nursing so
feeding on demand really every few hours
apparently he's a hungry little baby so
yes she looks a little bit tired berry
sure appreciates mommy Megan check out
this new bling he gifted her beneath her
engagement ring and her wedding band is
a new eternity ring and some people have
speculated that this was a push present
but I think in fact it was a first
anniversary present with a mom back home
in LA the new parents have now hired a
nanny to help them with Archie I've
heard from very reliable sources that
the new nanny who is now been appointed
by the success has had to find quite an
extensive non-disclosure agreement and
on Sunday it's Father's Day both here
and in the UK and you can count on Harry
to celebrate his first ever to mark
Father's Day with baby Archie's going to
be really special and if we're lucky who
knows we may even get a new glimpse on
Instagram
[Music]